hola amigos de radio canadá soy
homero transmitiendo desde praga
república checa
soy un radioyente muy frecuente de sus
programas y también los leo bastante y
escucho y veo su transmisión el judías
viernes que transmiten en vivo
aquí atrás mío se encuentran el castillo
de praga que es la representación más
famosa que existe en el país y al lado
mío está el río moldava como lo pueden
ver y en los de barquitos no surgió
bastante famoso no porque cruza toda la
ciudad
y bueno también contarles de que en una
semana el 28 de octubre se celebra 101
años de la fundación de checoslovaquia
jam y este sábado 20 de octubre también
informarles de qué son las elecciones en
bolivia
y yo voy a viajar hasta berlín para dar
mi voto en la embajada de bolivia
saludos desde praga a todos allá